bonjour à tous écoutez je tenais
simplement déjà vous dire que je suis
totalement séduit je pense clairement
que l'eau qui va surpasser wendat vision
et falcon tom hiddleston est incroyable
owen wilson aussi la bande son est ouf
la direction artistique j'en parle même
pas bref je suis vraiment très surpris
et très content après j'avoue mon avis
sera toujours un peu biaisé puisque
j'adore vraiment les récits qui sont
liées au temps n'oublie pas d'arc 1
évidemment bref outre ma satisfaction
nous sommes ici pour comprendre et
détaillé les mystères de la série law
qui avec une petite pincée de théorie
donc let's go tout d'abord quelque chose
m'avait fait un peu tiquer au début
c'est pourquoi les avengers n'ont pas
été punis pour leur casse temporel et
bien endgame était incroyablement bien
précis et la série nous a fait bien
comprendre la chose le casse des
avengers était prévu et non dangereux
car ils ont tout simplement ramener les
pierres à leurs époques respectives et
accessoirement où ils les ont récupérées
comme expliqué par l'ancien qui nous
avait introduit le fameux flux éternel
temporel sacré etc
ils ont enlevé les pierres le
juin 2021 à 17 heures admettons grâce un
voyage dans le temps bien calculé ils
les ont ramenés le 9 juin 2021 à 17h et
points voilà donc pas de nexus créer ou
de réalité alternative
ce qui d'ailleurs signifie que steve a
bel et bien effectué sa mission sans
problème sinon la tva serait intervenu
donc qu'il a rencontré red skull lui a
remis la pierre de l'âme et cetera mais
bon c'est pas trop le sujet et du coup
l'eau qui est bel et bien coupable car
il s'est sorti lui même du flux temporel
principal en s'échappant avec le
tesseract il a exploité une toute petite
erreur d abuja normalement sans
conséquence et cela a créé un nexus
nexus qui sera refermé dès les premières
minutes de l'épisode donc voilà pas de
nouvelles lignes temporelles mais du
coup c'est très intéressant car cela
veut dire que le retour de steve à son
époque était prévue et n'est pas
considéré comme problématique donc on va
avoir des suites à cette histoire
steve en restant avec peggy dans le
passé n'a pas créé de nouvelles lignes
temporelles ou nexus donc cela confirme
que pendant toute la saga du mc eu il y
a bel et bien de steve rogers en vie
celui que nous connaissons prisonnier de
la glace est un autre qui a fait sa vie
après endgame avec peggy et pareil pour
gamme aura cela semble normal et tolérer
que ces dernières provenant du passé
fasse un saut dans le temps dans le
futur et il reste je vous avoue que
cette fois ci je trouve ça un petit peu
étrange car cela ressemble au même cas
que loki mais bon bref
retournons sur la série on est avant
tout là pour s'interroger sur le tout
alors ce n'était pas mes fils tôt et ils
nous ont bien trop les pourtant méphisto
et très malicieux comme l'eau qui sort
ait fait un superbe antagonistes mais
bon effectivement beaucoup de théories
avaient circulé à propos du trailer de
loki concernant le vitrail représentant
le diable en tout puissant mephisto
était dépeint comme le diable c'était
gros comme une maison mais il s'avère
que ce n'est pas le cas
le méchant de la série serait
apparemment un lot qui variant qui donne
du fil à retordre à
la tva la scène du crime se déroulant en
1549 une époque plutôt médiévale donc
très tourné autour de l'église etc
il est plutôt facile de représenter
l'eau qui comme une sorte de diable
et ce fameux lot kim méchant justement
accumule les restaurateurs de temps
pourquoi cela déjà la scène de
l'interrogatoire entre mobius lots qui
est vraiment hyper intéressante cet
interrogatoire profond permettent à
mobile us de comprendre plus en
profondeur qui est véritablement loki sa
véritable nature et donc ne plus se
baser seulement sur les faits de son
histoire comme il nous l'a montré avec
des séquences
il cherche à comprendre son ennemi est
mieux que ça encore vu la complexité du
personnage de loki qui de mieux que loki
pour comprendre et appréhender un autre
look in mind games l'eau qui ne semble
pas approuver la tva
l'idée que sa vie soit en fait dicter du
début jusqu'à la fin
ce qu'on appelle le destin finalement et
si justement l'eau qui n'approuvent pas
cela c'est que le look yves variant ne
l'approuvent pas non plus et c'est un
détail important puisque cela peut
justifier ses actions
et puisque l'eau qui a toujours eu soif
de règne et de grandeur il doit y avoir
une signification liés à ces thématiques
dans les actes du lot qui variante étant
donné qu'ils ciblent la tva et les
restaurateurs de temps peut-être
cherche-t-il à contrôler la tva est donc
régné sur le temps possiblement après
tout le temps semble être une énergie
encore bien plus puissante que le
tesseract et donc les pierre d'infini
néanmoins nous restons face à un lot qui
encore inconnue on ne sait pas de quelle
époque il vient et surtout il est
capable de voyager dans le temps comme
le montrent les scènes de crime
répartis à travers le temps mais dans la
logique vu que l'eau qui dans le flux
principal doit mourir face à tan hausse
durant les événements dignes finity war
donc en 2018 si je ne dis pas de bêtises
et bien cela veut dire que le lot qui
variant s'est échappé avant cette date
fatidique
donc cela permettrait de comprendre
pourquoi pas la mentalité qu'il avait à
ce moment là même mmm je vous avoue que
j'ai trois petits soucis
oui dès l'épisode 1 c'est ça peut mener
à une certaine conclusion d'ailleurs
déjà nous sommes face à une série du mc
eu et nous en avons déjà connu deux pour
le moment ces fameuses séries sont
reliés aux films qui dont le
fonctionnement de la saga reste les
oeuvres majeures
les séries sont en quelque sorte là pour
introduire les films comme wendat vision
avec doctor strange deux falcon avec
black widow et captain america 4 nous
avons aussi l'exemple de la série
prochaine sur miss marvel introduisant
derrière sa zee miles soit captain
marvel 2 et cetera et cetera
donc même si l'eau qui semble être une
série un peu à part comme déclaré par
kevin fait guy nous gardons quand même
ce schéma en tête
et justement ces petites séries marvel
sont là également pour entretenir la
hype et la perdurer jusqu'au dernier
épisode alors la mécanique de nous
dévoiler le méchant ultime dès le
premier épisode je trouve ça un peu
étrange surtout concernant une série
vendue comme très mystérieuse et à part
cela m'étonnerait fort que la série soit
juste on cherche le méchant loup qui ont
le bas et fin de l'histoire
et justement par rapport à salo qui est
un personnage qui a un peu de mal à se
gérer tout seul surtout concernant de
grandes ambitions ou un plan ultime
si comme dit dans l'interrogatoire les
actes de méchanceté sont une illusion
qui sont là pour générer une certaine
peur c'est que cela doit être le cas
certainement ici aussi
et si l'eau qui a les moyens de voyager
dans le temps et de mettre à mal la tva
c'est qu'il a dû certainement être et
des lots qui n'a jamais été au courant
de l'existence d'une telle entreprise et
ce jusqu'à sa mort face à la noce
donc voilà alors
et si le lot qui variant agissait pour
je sais pas moi
kang le conquérant kang a été annoncée
pour être le vilain de huntsman trois
cantons magna et ce n'est pas du tout un
vilain aléatoire kang est liée au temps
et à la tva
pareil ce n'est pas du hasard s'il est
le méchant deux ans 23 le champ
quantique tout ça les voyages dans le
temps on connaît ce dernier est très
iconique et très puissant il serait un
ennemi terrible face aux avengers et
surtout ils collent parfaitement pour
tout que ce soit la thématique du
multivers des voyages dans le temps
interdit donc un ennemi de la tva tva
dont justement il a eu une liaison avec
la jugera vos narines slayer dans les
comics cela permettrait également de
créer implose twist dans la série
faisant une loki variant un méchant de
première instance avant de dévoiler la
véritable menace que nous reverrons dans
antoine 3 d'ailleurs c'est la reproduire
le schéma de l'eau qui avec thanos qui
restait bien caché dans l'ombre car oui
je le rappelle danos avait envoyé loki
sur terre pour récupérer le tesseract en
échange de lui offrir la terre quoi donc
nous serions face un lot qui variant qui
reproduirait les mêmes erreurs qu'à un
lot qui du flux principal car du coup il
agirait pour kang qui est bien cachée
qui restent dans l'ombre et qui n'est
toujours pas décelé par la tva et j'irai
peut-être même un peu plus loin en
affirmant que le lot qui variant est un
lot qui
d'avant le tout premier avengers sinon
pourquoi il aurait reproduit le même
schéma qu'avec thanos du coup donc
autant avoir un look et qui n'a pas
encore connu
ça se travaille avec thanos et qui du
coup le ferait avec angles conquérant
bref peut-être que quand on lui a promis
une réalité dont il serait le dieu roi
dont il a toujours rêvé mais ce serait
un plans contrecarrés par le lot qui que
nous suivons qui à terme deviendrait la
meilleure version de lui même comme
expliqué par mobius avec les avengers
enfin voilà j'avoue que je pars un petit
peu loin surtout en plus dès le premier
épisode mais sincèrement je pense que
cette série va être une dinguerie je
suis déjà méga fan et j'ai vraiment hâte
de voir la suite
dites moi vous dans les commentaires
d'ailleurs ce que vous en pensez de
cette série si la vidéo vous a plu vous
pouvez bien évidemment vous abonner à la
chaîne me laissait un petit pouce bleus
et puis nous reparlerons de loki très
très bientôt ne vous en faites pas
n'hésitez pas non plus à me suivre sur
les réseaux et coûté 7 et argo rock et
que le lionheart soit avec vous allez
ciao tout le monde
[Musique]